i've got to live forever i've got three
daughters and a wife and a life i i
can't die
there's nothing bob saget loved more
than his family and now his daughter
lara is opening up about their special
relationship it's a it's a love thing
that's kind of what it is in her first
post since the full house star's
unexpected death on january 9th the 32
year old touches on her dad's
unconditional love and the lessons he
taught her lara shares this black and
white throwback of the two and a
heartfelt message in the caption reading
in part quote unconditional love is the
greatest of gifts my dad loved with
everything he had he had so many reasons
to be scared to love so many loved ones
kept dropping the body instead of being
scared he loved more i am beyond
grateful to receive and to give that
love
lara says it's these lessons he taught
her that feel the most important it's a
gift to be able to be with people and
make them laugh
bob's widow kelly rizzo reposted larry's
tribute with a sweet message the love
for his girls is otherworldly and
unmatched he's just the most pure heart
ever
and that's one thing the lay actor is
known for by all who knew him when you
care about somebody
especially now i'm finding you got to
let them know
bob who also has two other daughters
aubrey and jennifer valued his loved
ones above all else here's what he said
in his last interview with e.t i think
just like any
any dear dear friends do
and when you have friends
or family sometimes you're closer with
your friends than your family it depends
on the relationships you have it's nice
to get that
heart emoji back
or whatever you get back even if it's
full-on dialogue you know sometimes
texting is a gift not a curse
one person who knew bob's heart his
friend ben stiller what i really
remember about him is
his
his energy his warmth and
his
outgoing
just love that he had for people when
e.t caught up with the zoolander star he
shared how bob was there for his family
after his parents and meera and jerry
stiller died he was always reaching out
um and when my when i lost both my
parents he was all he was there for our
family um he loved my parents my parents
loved him over the years and uh you know
that's what i take away is is the heart
that he had and the way he touched so
many people which i think you felt when
when we lost him
but just a genuinely
good person